Drew loves Elmo
and Drew is so excited to announce,
Elmo is our next guest!
Hello!
(audience cheering)
(Elmo laughing)
Oh, hi, Ms. Drew.
(Elmo giggling)
Oh, Elmo.
Hi! Elmo's so happy to see you.
I'm so excited that you're here joining us
on our daytime show.
That's right.
Let me ask you-
Yeah.
What's it like having a late night,
not so late night show?
Yeah it, well you know,
Elmo's bedtime is 7:30.
(audience laughing)
So it's like, it's not that late
but it's not early.
No, its fun. We have a really good time.
You know, Elmo is really having a great time doing a show
with all of his friends.
You know, Bert and Ernie are the director.
(Drew gasping)
Yeah, and Rosita's the stage manager.
And you know what? We have a helper chicken, named Felix.
He helps around the studio.
Do you have a helper chicken?
I actually have six chickens, Elmo.
They're my daughters
and they, we all adopted them
when they were tiny baby chicks,
they would fit in the palm of our hands
and we raised them since they were babies.
The chickens?
Yeah.
Elmo's gonna have to think about that one.
(audience laughing)
(Elmo laughing)
Well, Elmo hopes that we can meet them.
Oh, I would love to introduce you
to our chickens.
Okay.
We have Percy, Pepper, Blanche, Sparkles, Ferdinand-
Ooh.
And
Blanche!
(Elmo laughing)
Well, that's great! Elmo can't wait to meet them.
You know what's interesting about today, Elmo.
What's that?
Guess who's gonna get to be
on your not so late show this evening?
Well, Elmo's gonna give a little bit of a spoiler alert,
but Ms. Drew did The Not-Too-Late Show.
(audience cheering)
It's true.
We were so lucky to have on our show.
Oh, I'm so honored.
I can't think of a show that exists on the planet,
let alone television,
that I wouldn't be more excited to be on
than your show, Elmo.
Thank you for having me.
Well, Elmo's blushing.
You can't tell, 'cause Elmo's red
but Elmo is blushing.
(Elmo chuckling)
Well, I wanna ask you,
what is your favorite part about having your own show?
Well, you know, Elmo gets to meet a lot of new friends.
You know, the contestants come in and their kids
and they come in with their mommies or daddies
or grand parents or caretakers.
And we get to play and dance and have a great time.
Oh, that is just so wonderful.
Now, let me ask you a question
because I have a lot of homework every night-
Right.
For the show and guests.
Do you have a lot of homework?
Well, Elmo didn't know that Elmo was supposed
to research the guests,
until it was like a little too late.
(Drew and audience laughing)
But you know, that's what Google's for.
Elmo just did a quick Google search.
Well, it's funny 'cause you're a really good teacher.
Really?
Oh yeah. Oh yeah.
Well, Elmo thinks teachers are very important.
Yeah. I think you've pretty much taught us a lot about
what we know.
Really?
Oh sure.
I can think of so many lessons I've learned from you,
whether it's about how
to take care of a fish to-
Yes.
How important it is to be kind to each other.
Well, you know, it's interesting 'cause does have a fish,
named Dorothy.
Oh, yeah.
But Elmo also just got a brand new puppy.
Yeah.
And yeah, her name is Tango
and Elmo's learning a lot about how to take care of a dog
and it's, you know it's really hard taking care
of a dog, Drew.
They run around, they, you know,
they go to the bathroom.
(audience laughing)
Yes.
Elmo didn't even think about that.
Elmo just said, Elmo wants a dog and then,
who knew?
(audience and Elmo laughing)
Do you know-
But we're having
a great time.
Elmo loves his doggy.
One time my dog went to the bathroom inside my shoe.
And that was, that was a real surprise.
(audience laughing)
That's why Elmo doesn't wear shoes.
(everyone laughing)
Well, since the leaves are turning-
Yeah, it's beautiful in here.
Oh-
Look at all the leaves.
Thank you.
Really pretty.
It's becoming fall, which is such a beautiful season, and-
Yeah.
I wanted to see
if you would play a little game with us.
Okay, sure.
Okay.
It's called Fall Faves.
Fall Faves.
Elmo, that's great.
(Elmo laughing)
(audience applauding)
Okay. I'll list two classic fall things
and we'll choose which is our fall favorite.
Okay.
And our audience gets
to play along too.
So you guys have the green side be your first choice
and the red side be your second choice.
Elmo, are you ready?
Ready!
Okay. Let's see. Here we go.
Do you like apple cinnamon or pumpkin spice?
Ooh, pumpkin spice!
Let's see.
Apple cinnamon is green.
Pumpkin spice is red.
Oh.
Okay. 50/50.
I was just gonna say, even-Steven.
Yeah.
Who is Steven?
Why do we say that?
Yeah, who is Steven? Can we get that answer, please?
Who's Steven?
Yeah.
(audience laughing)
Talk about a Google search, Elmo.
I'm gonna do that tonight.
(Elmo giggling)
Okay.
You know, what's funny?
What?
How about this?
Do you know why they say it's raining cats and dogs?
Yeah, why do they say that?
Because back in the old days,
when houses were made from adobe and mud,
the cats and dogs would go up in the rafters
and when it would rain, it would get so muddy,
they would slip down,
so they'd fall from the ceiling.
That's crazy!
Isn't it crazy?
You learn something new every day.
That's exactly right.
Yeah.
Okay. Spooky or cozy?
Ah, look at that.
Well, Elmo has to, because it's fall,
Elmo's got to say spooky.
(audience and Elmo laughing)
All right. Green for spooky, red for cozy.
Elmo.
I think that's another-
Looks like it's a even-Steven.
Yeah.
(everyone laughing)
That's right.
Yeah.
Okay. Sweaters or jackets?
Oh, sweaters or jackets?
See this one's difficult for Elmo
'cause I was already very warm
with the fur
but just for the sake of a game,
Elmo's gonna say sweaters.
You kind of do have-
Elmo's kind of a sweater.
Yeah, exactly!
(Elmo laughing)
It's true!
Well then just for that, I'm gonna say sweaters as well.
Okay.
What about you guys?
Sweaters or jackets?
That's pretty close, pretty close.
Yeah, it's a little even-Stevens still.
Yeah.
Maybe a little
more sweaters.
Yeah.
All right. Last one.
Trick
for green.
Red
for treat.
Oh, Elmo's got to say treat.
Treat.
And guess what?
Look.
Wow! Look at that!
In honor of you, it's all red.
Everybody likes a treat.
Yeah, that's right.
(Elmo laughing)
(upbeat music)